oh yes I'm her mom your mom I'm her mom
so and how come you're here you gave her
a ride yes I gave her a ride here today
I truly believe that you know if she
chooses to try something new and I'm not
you know aware of the company or the
people that she's going to I just want
to make sure that she's safe and and
that's why I brought her today to kind
of check things out for myself
yeah for yourself hang out for yourself
cuz she wanted some what that thing and
you you know so what are you bringing
her here to do today
well she had answered an ad I guess her
girlfriend had told her about this
opportunity for some modeling and it's
not supper where this is not perfume
this is not a vine this is the
opportunity is to get paid to get [ __ ]
how do you know I don't know man it
looks like a boy funny things like I
never said anything I thought to show
this video and he's convinced dude I'm
good it could not be nothing else they
bout to get I found out that it was
after over four adult sites you know
Marlene for adult works but don't worry
basically you know porn porn
Masha for got me
so we kind of went back and forth we
talked about it a little bit and you
know not that I completely condone it
but she's also her own person and she is
an adult so she has that opportunity to
make up your mind on her own and why you
standing next to her though cuz you
about the giddy defending way to close a
bap today honey whatever she chooses to
do I want to be there to support her and
you know just make sure that she's safe
doing whatever she's gonna do pretty
much finished I tell you and just told
you you have a very open relationships
never open relays
[ __ ] you just don't you she just tells
you [ __ ] up ceiling you can't say no
my she was like wait way my main concern
again and like I said it's safety you
know who are the people who who are
providing this you know opportunity how
long have they been in business that's
why you did your mail then you'll make a
girl hook you know
don't [ __ ] fool yourself okay if you
want your daughter you don't mind your
daughter to be the doing point and you
just want to check out the opportunity
and you want to be safe let's say I come
in the room I'm not that kind of person
but let's say I come in the room and I
[ __ ] this whole [ __ ] up like you're all
[ __ ] up like a [ __ ] you all I [ __ ]
your daughter up everybody [ __ ] up
leave stretch out of this [ __ ] I put my
foot up your ass
surely you understand what I'm saying
and I scar you for life I do some bad
things to you let's say I do that what
the hell you gonna do for your safety
hey you two cute ladies but I'm a 200
230 pound [ __ ] how about this
let's say would have been a gangbang we
ain't [ __ ] up in this [ __ ]
what the hell you gonna do about this
[ __ ] what what this was not for safety
stop playin yourself don't try to act
like you a good mother and then she just
being there for the safety of your child
you don't wanna be able to do nothing
alright you're calling me stupid in my
face now like it I know him gonna think
- shut the [ __ ] up with your [ __ ] you
know you just wanted that D and get them
with it cuz you call it an opportunity
with an opportunity what [ __ ] I
don't wanna be there call this [ __ ] and
importunate see what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what are you even talking
about why why are you showing me this
what is going on what what's going on
so do what you need pulling yourself
you know I like the most about this
video an interview does not give a [ __ ]
about this this is the same interview
for all the videos not most of them and
this dude does not care what the girls
in it so he goes straight to the next
yeah safety okay do you like porn
yourself mom like does not give us [ __ ]
right it's it's adventurous it kind of
gives you new ideas lets you exact your
turn i faith about what our mom is fine
that means you had you went through some
fault poor gia do you think you do want
to see her video oh that's a tough
question I'm gonna dance or no on that
we'll keep some things private
Oh what about do you think you ever do
one yourself I have thought about it in
the past but you're nice and I think my
numbers are up now so no I I kind of
think that I'll leave that to that
Yonkers cuter girls maybe you guys can
come back and do what together I'm not
sure she would let me her answer was not
sure if she would let me so if not no
hell no I don't bounce night that no
your only thing is your daughter is what
you will want or not cuz you would be
down but you get up into this I think so
darkness pain no II think I think no no
we haven't
so you guys came drove down today just
does your husband and your father know
you mean well he knows we're here
right well thank you for dragging her
down today and making sure she was safe
when her first client I was Lydia she
did she did good Shinya Thanks
mostly good and pontius oh of course she
didn't do good okay so it was just an
interview yeah I was able after the
point shoot yeah she did very good
they're gonna do another one
I'll give her a nine out of ten really
[ __ ] is that what it's why am I even
touching this deal now I gotta watch my
whole [ __ ] I got no thoughts on this
video that's it great video if you guys
haven't seen it and let me see what
number of girls do porn I'll put the
number below and yeah alright so that's
it for today's video if you guys like
that be sure to LIKE subscribe Facebook
YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you wanna
donate a little bit of money you know
give us a little thumbs up then we do it
I definitely went the wrong direction
job well that's yes so you know thanks
holler a dollar makes me holler